our database will contain weather
forecasts entries our data model will
use two tables one table will be used to
contain information about the location
while the other will contain the
forecast data key to the locations these
will ultimately be tied back to our view
through the contract and the content
provider we can use an inner join to
pull the complete data for each forecast
today including all information about
the location this is a big contract note
that we store the location ID which will
be a foreign key from the location table
in column Lok key note that the units
aren't stored in the database we expect
all weather entries to be stored in
metric units and converted when needed
by the UI into imperial units since the
column names don't actually contain data
types it's useful to annotate that in
the variable names and/or the comments
to make our contract more explicit